Dans "Pourquoi On Dit ?",
je vous raconte cequi se cache
derrière les expressions de la langue française.
Alors abonnez-vous et
surtout, n'oubliez pas la cloche !
Salut lesÉpicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Savez-vouspourquoi on dit :
"Être comme cul et chemise" ?
Cette expression signifie être
très proche dequelqu'un, voir inséparable
et pour cause,
avant le 19e siècle,
la chemise pouvait être portéeà même le corps
pendant plus d'un mois, sansêtre lavée.
Inséparable donc, du corps qui laportait.
À l'époque, bien-sûr, elle ne ressemble pas
à celle que l'on porte aujourd'hui.
Pas decol ni de manche à gousset.
Des pièces de tissu triangulaires
que l'on retrouve sous lesaisselles.
La chemise ressemblait plutôt
à une simple tunique composée de deux pans de tissu.
Apparaître en public,
nu en chemise,
c'est-à-dire, juste avec une chemise,
pouvait mêmeêtre vécu comme une humiliation.
La chemise était donc une pièce de lingerie
intime prochedu corps et du cul.
Cet ancien usage de la chemise
et les règles d'hygiène
n'ont commencé à évoluer
qu'à la fin du 18e siècle,
ce n'est d'ailleurs qu'à partir de
cette époque qu'on a commencé
à changer d'avis comme de chemise.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser unpouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux.
Pour les plus gourmands en voici d'autres et
pour nerien rater abonnez-vous et activez la cloche !